and as we saw in that Duda versus Pride
game it's all about the mouth skills and
uh we'll see the moves come flying on
the board the Spanish opening which we
saw earlier today between these two
Magnus allows the open Spanish if black
captures in the center he does but
Magnus chooses a different variation
than the first rapid game of the day and
this is Mainline Theory this is very
well known stuff White's porn stepping
forward now
will we see black capture in a moment on
this Square this is I think called the
Dilworth variation uh very very tactical
stuff Magnus has barely spent any time
Liam's barely spent any time I've seen
both players have this position in Rapid
games on the tour right now there was a
sacrifice there by black but black has
given up two pieces in return he got a
rook and two pawns so if we do a count
black is actually one point up but
White's minor pieces are phenomenal
whites minor pieces are very strong and
I remember a game Magnus beat Hans
Neiman on the tour earlier this season
with the white side aha of this opening
I also remember that game I also
remember Liam Lee also playing this with
the black pieces against Jordan van
forest and the two are still playing
into the main line this has all been
seen before night goes to the edge of
the board and the main line is actually
for the queen to move one square across
the diagonal to threaten to pin the
queen and Rook yeah I'm really surprised
by this decision by Magnus he's played
into an opening he knows that Liam has
studied in depth Leanne has played all
of these moves almost instantly and it's
very theoretical black should be fine
Black's Pawns in the middle of the board
look great but uh yeah it's just so
complicated so uh hard to put a finger
on in terms of what the plan should be
often it's just moved by move and that
is just about pure speed maybe Magnus is
playing on the Glock but uh yeah I think
objectively maybe it would have been a
safer decision to play something really
kind of strange where he is simply
stronger than Liam especially with the
extra minute and I can tell you that by
Liam retreating that night has gone into
his own preparation so no one had ever
played that move before and Liam this is
his home-cooked idea and he moves his
King to the edge of the board getting
out of the eye line of the light squared
Bishop this is a I think this is a good
Blitz approach oh Magnus however is
starting to create some threats so
Black's King is much safer now but it
did cost a valuable move a valuable
Tempo and White's Queen White's night
White's Bishops they're all perfectly
placed to attack those black Pawns in
the middle of the board all white needs
to do really is to start improving his
Knight at the bottom the White Knight
next to his king is not doing anything
that's why the bishop steps back the
White Knight is going to actually jump
to the square that that Bishop
previously occupied
so uh yeah it's very tense does black
touch any of those Pawns in the center
of the board if you touch those black
pawns you might weaken squares so yeah
it's really difficult for Liam the time
situation still more than a minute
Advantage for Magnus so that is already
critical that could play a huge part in
the result yeah and Liam facing pressure
in the center he has to defend his pawns
so that's why he steps forward with the
bishop that's a good move just breaking
the coordination between The Rook Knight
and queen
um Magnus will be itching to give up his
Rook for this bishop it's just I've
talked to Magnus enough times he wants
to sacrifice he hates his opponents
having nice Pawn structures he's going
to be very tempted to use his rook and
sacrifice it for the bishop doubling up
Black's Pawns in the center but I don't
think you should get carried away with
anything flashy here you just need to
play quickly keep the pace he's still a
minute ahead although that's ticking
down now the white Knights can move you
can protect one night with the other
Knight for example
you have lots of ideas here for white
but you just need to trust your instinct
slowed down he slowed down I I reckon
he's considering your move Rook takes
Bishop that's why he's paused for
thought and uh he's got his music on and
Armageddon you shouldn't get carried
away even if it's a strong move even if
sacrificing here
getting that black Bishop off the board
even if it's good why waste one whole
minute of an Armageddon game on that
just play a simple move move one of the
white Knights and he's now only got 20
second time advantage over Liam Lee and
he has to make a move
I I think he has to commit to something
you know I for me I would be
springboarding with my knight to G5 just
put some pressure on that Bishop oh gosh
she spent a minute and a half on one
move it's Armageddon there's no
increments he's now down on the clock
minus Carlsen then he has to win this
game and then he plays maybe the most
natural move on the board that he could
have played this instantly he defends
one night with the other one and uh now
the Queens are coming off the board
however so we saw an exchange Magnus
shook his head maybe that was just
because of how slow he was playing
he looks like he's still fine on the
board you can trade off the Queens if
you want to along that diagonal the
White Knight can move away
it looks like white is stable with his
minor pieces and uh Liam's Pawn on D5 is
being attacked so he has to defend that
perhaps attack the bishop the Knight
sorry Knight jumps forward also very
good and uh yeah has a Time advantage
over Magnus that is going to be huge
that time Advantage it could play a huge
world of clock because it's such a
blocked position Suddenly It's very
similar actually in terms of mentality
to that prag versus due to Armageddon
it's going to come down to a position
that's blocked and it's just about who's
quicker on the mouse and okay we do see
an exchange of Pawns not 100 sure about
that from Liam because now it's slightly
less blocked he could have maybe just
locked things down and played on the
clock but now can you kick away White's
knight from the center that is the key
Black's Rooks need to find open lines in
to get towards those two white pawns on
the left for example but how do you do
that if white stabilizes if white
secures his Knight in the center then
Magnus is just in control and now it's
Liam's turn to have a think where he
considers what to do and he pushes the a
pawn so he's got the same idea as you
David he wants to attack the people but
yeah it may be too slow it's very very
slow and Magnus is now going to start
jumping forward attacking a weak Pawn
that black Pawn on the A5 square that
Liam has just kind of put there as a
Target Magnus is going to try and grab
it and suddenly it's Liam he's playing
with fewer pieces remember a rook is not
as good as a bishop at night so uh black
has two Rooks white has three pieces to
play with it's slightly easier the more
pieces you have in general despite what
the pawn count is and Magnus he's
insisting he's stubborn he's going after
that black apron
and uh now 35 second time advantage
yeah maybe the clock will decide this
game on the board it's still looking
good for white however that moment where
Magnus throws for one and a half minutes
maybe you spent the time well just uh
choosing a safe variation yeah and Liam
now under a minute
49 seconds on the clock and he's just
struggling both on and off the board
speed up I mean regardless of what he
has to do okay so he gives up the a pawn
fine just uh keep on making those moves
keep on putting pressure on Magnus now
this Pawn will be captured however uh
Magnus I think he's just going to take
it back with his own Pawn the one thing
that white should not do is exchange a
set of Rooks now if you take with
White's Rook then you're only left with
your minor pieces normally you want one
of everything you oh wow he really does
push his foot forward and capture
normally you want to keep pieces on the
board and Liam now complicates the issue
by throwing his Pawn forward now his
idea is to go for checkmate he's going
for the white king I thought he would
just exchange Rooks I thought maybe he
would be okay there but Magnus finds a
nice counter-attacking move rather than
Retreat the white Bishop he's forcing
off for trade of Rooks he has won two
Pawns in the process so now it's okay
to swap Brooks and now that those have
left the board Liam is left with a
ruined position he's down on material
he's down on the clock 20 seconds it's
not enough it's not enough no he and
look at him he just moves his King and
uh White has the dream position the
bishop and Knight are coordinating
beautifully and he captures a pawn I
mean more or less Magnus can play
anything because with 19 18 seconds left
on the clock there's nothing Liam can do
yeah he just lost the speed at the wrong
moment Liam and a couple of blunders
happened where he lost pawns due to the
situation on the clock and Magnus he's
reasserted control everything's uh
defended okay he grabbed another Pawn
it's just uh it was like Hungry Hippos
Magnus grabbed one point another pawn
another pawn another Pawn all of black
spawns have disappeared and Liam rather
than try and race on the clock she has
resigned Magnus takes the win wow what a
dramatic match
with